all of us will stop at nothing to drive
you happy we'll drive you happy
at carvana you might recognize these
commercials for carvana the online car
dealer that delivers cars to your home
or sends them to one of their vending
machines spread across the country
the company says it wants to change the
way we buy cars and in 2021 investors
took notice
its revenue had more than doubled from
the previous year and its stock value
skyrocketed by over a thousand percent
from a low point in 2020. i think carvan
is a perfect example of a stock that had
everything go right for it during the
first part of the pandemic and
subsequently seems to have almost
everything going wrong the company's
share price started to fall in late 2021
plummeting by 95 percent over several
months and the things that had once
driven carvana's growth were now
signaling trouble to investors
so
what went wrong
carvana has never actually posted an
annual profit instead focusing on growth
carvana put money into hiring into
new reconditioning centers to fix up the
cars that they buy and sell them again
harvard has put a lot of money into
marketing including the big super bowl
ads and things like that did i tell you
i bought our car from carvana but also
the car vending machines they spend a
lot of money and they have always spent
a lot of money and they don't make a lot
of money the company grew steadily and
went public in 2017 but it was in 2020
amid the pandemic when the share price
really took off
in february 2021 ceo ernie garcia talked
to cnbc about carvana's growth i think
what kova did is it shifted psychology
faster in the direction of trying new
things and so i do think that the
business probably has more demand today
than it would have had pre uh absent
coveted as demand increased three main
things were helping fuel growth for the
company
one was its method for accounting for
car loans
like other auto dealers carvana offers
customers loans to buy their cars and
sells the debt to investors who buy
bonds of the claim on customer loan
payments this is a process called
securitization but unlike others carvana
offloads its loans from its balance
sheet to make a gain upfront rather than
making a gain over time
low interest rates at the time helped
make the loans appealing to those
investors who had a higher risk appetite
and were more comfortable with consumer
credit in 2021 carvana made 37 percent
of the company's gross profit from gains
on loan sales
the second thing fueling growth was the
rising cost of used cars a global chip
shortage restricted production of new
cars sending up the cost of used ones
this benefited dealers across the market
and the third was its online low contact
model which allowed cars to be bought
and sold across states
the process that carvana promises is
appealing to a lot of people you don't
have any salespeople you know what your
price is you know that you have
financing going in like it's kind of
like a one click you know you can buy a
car
from your living room carvana's platform
was ideal for a social distancing world
and its stock followed the trend of
other virtually focused companies they
were you know really thriving during the
pandemic stock was on a steady upward
trajectory
and then the wind changed direction
after the peak in august share value
started to slip
spikes in coveted cases supply chain
issues and rising inflation began to
spook investors
i think it started with kind of a
broader growth stock pullback they were
like other companies that struggled with
the pandemic high expectations like
peloton and netflix in february the
company announced that it would acquire
used car auction business odessa us for
2.2 billion to expand their physical
locations for inspecting and
reconditioning cars
but in april the company announced their
first ever decline in quarterly sales
and share value dropped
with carvana you know they had this
growing demand they raced to meet this
demand they grew they grew they grew and
then all of a sudden you know the tide
kind of turns
demand isn't there for whatever reason
or isn't there to the level that they
expected and now investors are looking
you know kind of at the nitty-gritty of
the business because it seems like
growth isn't going to be the story the
tailwinds that had contributed to
carvana's growth and boost in stock were
now becoming headwinds
demand was cooling for their
securitizations fears grew that rising
inflation and a potential recession
would make it harder for car buyers to
pay back their loans
investors appetite for growth stocks and
consumer credit declined
used car prices were also becoming too
high for many buyers carvana said the
average price for their cars increased
by more than 30 percent from january
2021 to january 2022
and carvano was dealing with logistical
problems associated with the growth and
demand
complaints about the company were
growing carvana customers started
reporting having issues with um getting
the titles to their cars getting the
paperwork and time being provided with
temporary license plates from
states that they didn't live in and
those stories became more and more
common in the second half of last year
in november carvana said it was
addressing significant operational
constraints due to its record growth and
labor shortages due to covid however
many of these issues carried over into
2022
by may carvana's share price hovered
near low point the company announced
that it would lay off roughly 12 of its
workers after borrowing heavily to
acquire odessa
in july illinois moved to suspend
carvana in the state after complaints
about titles and registration the state
previously set strict guidelines for the
company around issuing temporary
registration and license plates carvana
was granted a temporary restraining
order to continue selling cars in the
state at the end of july
of the suspension a carvana spokesperson
said we provide title and registration
services at a rate among the top
performing dealers in the state carvanha
shares the state's commitment to
reducing paperwork challenges as much as
possible
so where does carvana go from here
quarter two earnings in august showed an
improvement in retail unit sales the
company said it is focusing on cutting
costs and improving efficiency it also
said it expects in the third quarter to
sell its loans to financial institutions
instead of packaging them into
securities its share price increased by
more than 40 percent the morning
following the announcement carvana's pop
ahead may depend on how it continues to
handle growth moving forward when
companies focus so exclusively on growth
they can you know generate all sorts of
demand for their product that they then
maybe struggle to meet that demand and
then by the time they catch up you know
the macro
environment and the demand for their
product for whatever reason whether it's
used car prices or
supply chain issues or whatever all
these kind of weird issues that affected
carvana's business they
were overbuilt for for what showed up a
carvana spokesperson said that the
company remains firmly committed to
continuous improvement and will stay
hard at work making the best car buying
and selling experience available even
better here's ceo ernie garcia in a
quarter two call to shareholders you're
reducing the speed at which we're
growing today given the shift in focus
but our hope and belief is that by
getting more efficient it makes it
easier to grow faster in the future
because you have kind of less work to do
per sale and so you know we'll hope to
get that back uh over time at some point
the auto industry as a whole has been
impacted by changing market conditions
but the share price for some competitors
like carmax have not been as severely
affected as carvana